-Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
Thank you for being here.
Thanks for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Please, enjoy yourself,
enjoy yourself.
Let's get to some news.
Well, guys, today,
The White House announced
major sanctions against Russia
for cyberattacks
and election interference.
Yeah, this is all in response to
Russia's repeated hacking.
Today, Biden told Americans,
"Rest assured,
when you log on to Netscape
and check your
AOL account, Jack,
it'll be secure."
When asked if he was
surprised by the sanctions,
Putin said, "No, I hacked e-mail
and saw on schedule last week."
Yep, the
Biden administration sanctioned
six Russian tech companies,
including their popular
streaming service, Nyetflix.
-Oh!
Nyet-- Because that's --
That's great.
-Yeah.
Thank you, thank you, bud.
But the Kremlin says
any U.S. sanctions are illegal.
-Ooh!
-I like how the country
that poisons people's underpants
is like, "No, hey, no,
that's not fair."
Yeah, the sanctions are
pretty harsh,
considering our past response to
election interference was
a letter that said...
"Um, no biggie if you can't,
Some more news
out of Washington.
Today, Congressional Democrats
introduced a bill
to expand the Supreme Court
from 9 to 13 justices.
Yep, Democrats
are thinking Americans have
gone up four sizes in
the last year.
Why not the court, too?
Of course, the Supreme Court
bench only fits nine people.
So if this goes through,
they're gonna add
a small folding table on the end
like it's Thanksgiving.
Well, this is big.
Today, the C.E.O. of Pfizer said
people will likely need
a third booster dose
within 12 months
of being fully vaccinated.
Oh, man, I can't believe
we have to go through
another year of vaccine selfies.
Another dose?
At this point people are
thinking, "You know what?
Screw it.
I'll take my chances with
the Johnson & Johnson."
Yeah, Americans are like,
"I want my life to be saved,
but I didn't know I'd have to go
to Rite Aid three times."
Some travel news.
A new CDC study found that
blocking middle seats
on airplanes reduces
the risk of COVID exposure.
More importantly, it reduces the
risk of you having to hear,
"Hi, I'm Corey."
I wish I had headphones.
I would put them on.
I think I speak for all men when
I say forget the middle seat.
Let's focus on blocking out
the middle urinal.
-Yeah!
-That's right.
-I mean, That's too close.
That's --
-Come on.
-Can we go sideways?
What are we --
Just pee in the same urinal.
What are we doing?
Well, guys, the Summer Olympics
are in less than 100 days,
and Ralph Lauren just unveiled
Team USA's
Closing Ceremony uniforms.
Take a look.
Yeah, there they are,
your Olympic athletes.
Oh, hang on.
Actually, they're here to set up
your cabana by the pool.
The athletes are coming.
Can we see that picture again?
Those uniforms look like
they're gonna tell me
about their summer abroad.
It looks like an ad for
a new sitcom called
"Let Me Speak to Your Manager."
Meanwhile, Team Canada
also debuted their outfits,
and the jackets are
getting some attention.
Look at this. Yeah.
I know we haven't been able to
visit Canada for a year,
but what the
hell happened up there?
Denim jackets
can only mean one thing --
they just got
"The Breakfast Club" in Canada.
-♪ Don't you
♪ Forget about me ♪
-Speaking of our neighbors
to the north,
yesterday, a Canadian lawmaker
was caught in the nude
during a virtual meeting.
Here's a photo.
-Oh!
-Being naked at home
is one thing,
but that guy was in his office.
How does that happen?
People alerted him right after
they took
a million screen shots.
Before putting on pants,
he was like,
"It's cold here today in Canada.
Isn't it cold?
Everyone's talking about
how cold it is."
Some entertainment news.
The new trailer for the latest
"Fast and Furious" movie, "F9,"
came out yesterday,
and it looks like it's still
the same "Fast and Furious"
that we all know and love.
Check it out.
-There's nothing
more important than family.
-Ugh!
[ Laughs ]
-Except friends.
But when your friends
are your family,
that makes them double family.
The only thing
that matters in life is
friends being
family being friends
while also being family,
a.k.a. friends, a.k.a. family.
"Framily" is what I call
my friends family.
And I'd do anything
for my framily or my fends,
which is what I call
my friends family's friends.
Now, what do you say?
Let's drive cars real fast.
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I got to go see that
with my framily.
Well, this is interesting.
Billions of cicadas will emerge
across the U.S. next month,
so a company is selling a
wearable bug-screen pod for $89.
Take a look at this thing.
Yeah, that's a bug screen
and definitely not
a guy who just cut armholes
in his hamper.
And, finally, a couple in
Australia was shocked
to find a live venomous snake
in a bag of lettuce
they bought at the supermarket.
Look at this thing.
-Oh!
-Yeah.
Australia was like, "We see
your shrimp tail, America,
and raise you a live snake."
And, meanwhile, if you count
the Canadian lawmaker,
that's two surprise snakes.
-Wow!
-We have a great show.